SNOW CALL ME CASINO SPORTS BOOKK
BROKEN UP BY WENNBERG.
THE SECOND TIME YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO GET THE PUCK OUT.
WHEN THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WHEN, I HAVE TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL.
GOT OF A SPACE.
A GREAT PASS
A STEAL.
KARSON KUHLMAN ANGLES OUT TO
THAT.
I THINK SOMETIMES
HERTL, WHO SCORED EARLY,
SHORTEING UP ON THE STICK IS
SOUCY.
HE SCORES!SOUCY.
WE HAVE SHEAHAN
KARLSSON, WHO GOES D-TO-D.
BACK OUT TO
HEAD.
SEES MEIER GOING
IT GOES DEEP IN THE SEATTLE
OUTSIDE.
HE HAS DONATO GOING TO THE NET.
>> JT: I WAS GOING TO SAY,
G.
THEY HAVE BEEN MOVING THEIR
FEET.
THEY HAV
SLID ALONG THE ICE
DETER THEM AND HAVE THEM SLOUCH
IN THEIR PLAY.
SOUCY ISIS
KICKED ALONG BY KARLSSON.
MOVED BUT NOT Y YAO HERE COMES
JOHANSSON.
HE WILL HIT T  POLICE ON ENTRY..
IT SAILED ALL THE WAYU ARE GOIN
BURNS.
IT'S A
GOOD HUSTLE BY DONSKOI.
HE WILL GET IT OUT.
BARABANOV DEFENDS  HERE
GOING IN RIGHT OFF THE WHAT DO A
THAT ALLOWS JARNKROK TO BE WIDE.
PUCK IS LOOSE.
FED ACROSS.
THEY SCORE.
IT'S TIMO  JIO GOES TO DANGLES .
PICKED OFF BY GOURD.
A HANDOFF FOR EBERLE. DIVING AC.
I AM NOT SURE IF THIS WAS IN